this video is sponsored by henson
shaving what do ikea founder ingvar
comprad sir richard branson billionaire
investor charles schwab walt disney and
henry ford have in common all are or
were successful entrepreneurs with
dyslexia a learning disorder that makes
it very difficult to read write and
spell people with dyslexia have trouble
connecting the letters they see to the
sounds they make and as a result often
struggle in school but in the real world
they thrive they're behind some of the
most successful companies on earth
richard branson is one of the greatest
entrepreneurs of our time he created
numerous businesses under the virgin
umbrella and has a net worth of 5
billion virgin who now employs 90 000
people would not have been successful if
i hadn't been dyslexic if you had told
branson's classmates that he'd achieved
this stunning level of success they may
have been dumbfounded branson was seen
as the dumbest person in school in his
words he had a hard time keeping up with
his peers because of his dyslexia and
dropped out at the age of 16. yet he
transformed his weakness into an
advantage branson credits dyslexia with
a success because he adapted his
management style to suit it which he
feels made him a better boss he
understood the importance of
communicating well he's famous for being
an inspirational leader who engages with
people his dyslexia also forced him to
delegate more i had to surround myself
with great people uh you know because i
wasn't good at um
at mass or something i you know had to
find people who were good at it one
example is when he hired an accountant
during the early days of virgin he
credits this with getting the company
off the ground branson always struggled
with numbers and words once when he was
in a board meeting at the age of 50 he
couldn't for the life of him understand
the difference between net and gross
profit one of the people in the room
kindly took him aside and explained it
to him with an illustration he drew the
ocean and put a net in the ocean with
fish in it he explained that the fish in
the net were the net profits and the
rest of the ocean was the gross turnover
and then everything became clear to
branson delegating tasks to the right
people is essential to growing any
business yet many find it difficult to
give up control everyone knows of a boss
who's a micromanager research has found
people with dyslexia are more likely to
delegate authority and also twice as
likely to own two or more businesses
that study out of cass business school
in london found more than a third of
american entrepreneurs surveyed showed
signs of dyslexia another commissioned
by the bbc found 40 percent of that
country's self-made millionaires showed
some signs of the learning disability
that's significantly higher than the
estimated five to ten percent of the
general population with some degree of
dyslexia the question is are their
entrepreneurial strengths a result of
nature or nurture a dyslexia expert
believes they are naturally better at
certain things like picking up social
cues in an article in the sacramento bee
about california governor gavin newsom
who has dyslexia dr mary lou gorno
tempini of uc san francisco said he can
understand what people need and their
emotions more than others i don't think
that's a compensation i think that's the
superpower of his dyslexic brain she and
other researchers at uc san francisco
recently discovered children with a
disorder had greater changes in heart
rate and facial behavior when they
viewed video clips of others
experiencing emotions compared to
children without dyslexia eleanor pulser
one of the researchers who conducted the
study concluded to newsthink this tells
us that dyslexia might be associated
with biological differences in empathy
being able to see things from the other
person's perspective is extremely
important for any entrepreneur walt
disney who was diagnosed with dyslexia
could read people very well and was
extremely empathetic according to those
who knew him he dreamt up a world that
children and adults could enjoy and
transform disney into an empire turns
out the brains of people with dyslexia
are wired differently university of
cambridge researchers used artificial
intelligence to map out the brain
differences of hundreds of children they
discovered those with dyslexia had
poorly connected hubs within the brain
which they attributed to their learning
difficulties you can liken these hubs to
a train station with few or poorly
organized connections so people with
dyslexia literally have a different way
of thinking and seeing the world their
unique brains are believed to make them
brilliant spies in fact some
intelligence agencies are actively
recruiting people with dyslexia such as
the uk's gchq the agency calls their
thinking skills mission critical because
they're great at spotting patterns that
others don't see crucial in trying to
prevent acts of terrorism for example
and increasingly important with warfare
moving into cyberspace as ai and machine
learning automate routine tasks creative
thinking skills could be in higher
demand and their creativity apparently
leads to original ideas that translate
into million dollar or billion dollar
success
no matter what business you're in the
goal is to make the product as desirable
as possible that brings me to the
sponsor of this video henson shaving the
maker of high quality safety razors that
i personally use they know a thing or
two about making a great product because
their razors are manufactured out of the
same machine shop in canada that built
parts for the international space
station the blade of a henson only
sticks out about half the thickness of a
human hair so there's less vibration
which results in much less irritation i
used to use disposable razors but i
realized it made sense to own a reusable
one henson shaving has a special
promotion just in time for christmas if
you use my discount code newsthink
you'll get a pack of 100 blades for free
be sure to add the 100 pack to your
shopping cart before using my code and
if you feel like treating yourself they
recently came out with their titanium
razor henson ships all around the world
if you'd like to try one out you can
head to my custom link in the
description
thanks for watching for newsthink i'm
cindy palm